foreign
hey everybody is this on
yes hey Shiloh
welcome to the table we're so glad that
you came tonight to uh spend your Sunday
evening with us my name is Josh I just
have a few announcements to get us going
tonight
um summer Rama Kids Camp is coming up
yeah so we're gonna have Maggie come and
talk about it yes
when are we going to have some around
well is the week the last week official
weekend of Summer every year we like to
kind of close out our summer with a kids
camp and it's sort of our alternative to
VBS we do a Friday and Saturday and then
into the service or you know then we'll
meet here that night for the service on
Sunday
um
I just went blank on my dates uh thank
you like wait August 4th uh Fifth and
6th and so
um we any any kids who are sixth grade
and under are
um welcome to that and if you have
teenagers who would like to volunteer
you are also very welcome last the last
year we had a group of five teenagers
who actually totally changed the entire
camp and they made it so worth it for
everyone made such an impact so
um you can come to me if you if you
think you have a team who would like to
help we they can help with music skits
songs any of that or be
um in one of the classrooms with the
kids or group leaders I should say not
really classrooms but we do crafts games
you know all the fun stuff so
um you can register for that on the
website you can also register to be a
volunteer if you're a parent or not a
parent and just think hey I like kids
and I could help out that weekend we
would love your help so definitely let
us know you can talk to me tonight
Brittany is over here she is like the
Headmaster of all things summer Rama so
um come find us if you have any
questions on that thanks Josh
all right
um so one more thing the month of July
at the table we like to kind of take a
break uh we want our Meetup Group
Leaders to take a break we encourage
them to take a break uh our pastor Brett
takes a break uh which is bummer because
we like hearing from Pastor Brett but
the Silver Lining is that we get to hear
from other people at the table uh who
get to come up and speak and tonight we
get to hear from Laurie
so we're real pumped about that
um
I think there was one more thing
no I think that's it
all right good I got all my points
before we go into worship uh if you
could just close your eyes if you're
anything like me
life is just hustle and bustle and a lot
of times we just try and rush through
things so just take some deep breaths
clear your mind
if you had a rough week try and push
that out and I want us to reflect on
something if you've ever heard of a guy
named e Stanley Jones
he was a missionary to India and uh
he wrote in one of his books this Indian
proverb which is beautiful
so just reflect on this before we get
started singing and worshiping tonight
be like the sandalwood tree
which perfumes the ax which cuts it
the more you cut it
the more you burn it
the more you grind it
the more fragrance its hoarded sap will
yield
I'll be reflecting on that one for a
little while
we're going to go ahead and get started
with our worship thank you Josh and I
just wanted to go ahead and introduce I
know we have new faces with us during
the summer months it can be especially
hit and miss I was just talking about
this how it's like you know you're out
one week and someone shows up and then
they're out the next week and you're
here and it's kind of like you're
missing each other so I just want to
take a second to let you know who we are
up on stage
um because this wall is not a dividing
wall okay it's this is just one big room
that we're all worshiping in together so
um this is Jesse and many of you know
him well
um he's been with us from the very
beginning of the table
um in different ways and then this is
Noel
and uh Noel is about to go off to
college so we're savoring our last
couple of sets with her and she's been
such a gift to our worship team into
this community Our Youth and so um this
is Caleb
um and if you guys weren't here I think
it was two weeks ago Caleb
um sang this song you should go back and
listen to the live feed he did an
excellent job with it and shared some of
his heart before it just coming out of
um some of his story and how he got here
so if you want to get to know Kayla a
little bit better go listen to two
Sundays ago the closing song it was it
was so meaningful and I just really
appreciated your vulnerability and we
love having you in in this group with us
and I'm Mindy and I'm just glad to be
here with you guys so y'all go ahead and
stand up and we're gonna get going and
I'm her mama
all right we're gonna start with love
has found us noelle's gonna kick us off
so you guys sing along if you know it or
clap your hands enjoy
thank you
[Music]
where can we run
where can we hide
is there a place that we can go where
you cannot find us
there when we fall
there when we rise
nothing is hidden from your face
you know every breath we dance
[Music]
it's all around us together
thank you
[Music]
nothing on Earth
below
[Music]
can take us from your love
you came to us
your own
[Music]
son
your love is
best
we are yours forever
[Music]
we will sing because
found us we are yours forever
[Music]
yes
will sing because
[Music]
all right we're gonna go ahead and
dismiss you kiddos to your classes bye
guys we'll see you after the service
thank you kids ministry volunteers and
teachers we're so grateful for you
have Joe and Zeke Brittany Angie
Maggie
sorry if I'm forgetting anyone
all right we're gonna transition into
the prayers of the people and if you're
new to this then we're going to read
through this prayer together and then
we'll have a space where you can share a
name or a situation that's heavy on your
heart you can just speak that out loud
and we're just going to hold that up
together before God believing that he's
here with us and that he cares about the
things that we care about he knows the
struggles and the pain that we have and
he wants to meet us in them
and then um after we have a moment for
that we'll go ahead and close out the
prayer again together and Caleb is going
to lead us in that prayer today so you
guys just follow along on the screen or
follow Caleb yep and if you're online as
well and you would like to list out a
name or put in a comment that'll be
lifted up as well and I'm just honored
to be able to lead you in this prayer
tonight so we will go ahead and get
started
[Music]
for this city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all who
live in them we pray to you
for The Good Earth you have given us and
the wisdom and will to conserve it we
pray to you
for the old and the sick for the Widow
and orphan for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you
for the vulnerable the marginalized and
those unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you
for those experiencing loss loneliness
and disconnection and for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health we pray to you Lord we know that
you love us and that you hear us so we
lift these names in situations up to you
[Music]
thank you
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts we pray to you that they may have
life and light healing and hope peace
and a deep sense of your presence amen
[Music]
foreign
and we're going to learn a new song
Tonight It's called um palm of your hand
um and actually someone in our community
had recommended it to me and it's just
been a meaningful song I was sharing
with our team earlier just that some of
the lyrics are straight out of passages
in the Bible that are kind of like
coming home scriptures for me like ones
that I come back to over and over and
continue to like feel grounded by
continue to sink into you know there's
always parts of the Bible that are you
know like I'm gonna have to chew on that
I'm gonna have to think on that I'm
gonna have to read on that I'm gonna
have to figure out you know
um and then there's those ones at least
for me that feel like a foundation and
and this song is kind of written from
some of those passages for me so I hope
that it carries some meaning in some way
even if they're new to you I hope that
it's someplace that you feel like you
can find some footing in the love of God
that doesn't let go that doesn't give up
that's not waiting nearby to judge us or
condemn us but that is ready to wrap its
arms around us to carry us home
foreign
[Music]
thank you
and if I'm being honest I know that
though you've said you said you've got
it no it's not easy letting go and trust
in you
so I will stop
breathe rest here in your goodness
[Music]
here in your goodness I know you won't
my confidence
foreign
let's sing that again from the top
[Music]
you
so I will stop
breathe rest here in your goodness I
know you won't believe it's my
confidence
I will stop
bring rest here in your goodness I know
you won't leave it's my confidence
[Music]
be the best here in your goodness I know
you won't leave it's my confidence
[Music]
it's my confidence
not a lie inside my head not a fear or
offense nothing can take me away
not a height nor a death not a fear
inside my head not a fear or offense
nothing can take me away let's sing that
again
[Music]
I'm not a lie inside my head not a fear
or a fence nothing can take me away
[Music]
yeah
everything could take me away
[Music]
sing here I am
here I am in the palm of your head
nothing can take me away nothing can
take me away yeah here I am
[Music]
nothing can take me away nothing can
take me away
here I am
nothing can take me away nothing can
take me away
[Music]
nothing can take me away
cause it's my confidence
it's my confidence my confidence it's my
confidence
it's my confidence
cause it's my confidence my
[Music]
husband it's my confidence
it's my confidence
nothing can take me away
[Music]
foreign
Foundation
[Music]
The Rock on which I stand when
everything around me is shaking
that I've never been more glad that I
put my faith in Jesus
cause he's never let me down he's
faithful through generations
so I would he feel now he wants
[Music]
and I've still got joy in chaos
I've got peace that makes no sense oh
everything around me is under
I'm not held by My Own Strength cause I
build my life on Jesus
cause he's never let me down he's
faithful in every season
so I would he feel now he was
[Music]
God
you won't fail
he won't face
[Music]
he won't fail
Christ is my firm foundation
The Rock on which I stand and everything
around me is
faithful through generations
so I would he feel now he was
he was
your face
[Music]
no
he won't
[Music]
foreign
my house was built on you
I'm safe with you
I'm gonna make it through and I'm gonna
make it through
cause I'm standing strong on you and I'm
gonna make it through cause my house was
built on you I'm gonna make it through
cause I'm standing strong on you
to make
crew cause my house was built on you
who
[Music]
I'm reminded of a hymn that says my
faith was built on nothing less
than Jesus Christ
and I feel like somewhere in my years
growing up as a Evangelical Christian I
somehow filtered in this message that
if your life is going well
you're loved by God when things are
working out you know he's on your side
you're his child he's going to look
after you that means things will not go
wrong
but the truth is that the love of God Is
Bigger Than circumstances it's bigger
than sickness it's bigger even than
death
the love of God holds us
it is our Center
it is our starting point and the place
that we come home to
[Music]
it is not a ticket out of jail
is not an escape from our pain
it is a love that comes right into the
midst of the pain and holds us when we
are broken
that puts us back together when we can't
see a Way Forward
thank you
it's a love that's stronger than this
world and what we face in it
foreign
God would our lives be built on Jesus
on the love
that you displayed on the cross
sacrificially laying your life down
so that we could experience wholeness
and healing and freedom and redemption
and forgiveness and Hope
would we come back home to that kind of
love
[Music]
thank you God
thank you for leading us through
we're grateful for this time together
in Jesus name amen
it's for worshiping together with us
would you guys turn to the people around
you
um maybe meet someone if you haven't
before say hello to an old friend make
people feel welcome
thank you
all right
so I have 17 pages of notes
and we're going to go through every
single one of them all right no so as
Josh mentioned earlier my name is Lori
provin I've been attending the table
church for about a year I think
officially
we've been members for two weeks so um
if you're new here so were we so as I
know it's hard to walk into a strange
place but you're always welcome here
I'm only going to say a little bit about
myself and just to let you know that
I've done this before
you're in good hands I was a formerly in
Tennessee in the Holston Conference of
the United Methodist Church I was what
they called a certified lay speaker so
that basically meant that on Sunday if
they didn't have somebody to preach they
could call me and I would show up and do
it I couldn't marry people couldn't bury
people there was one notable exception
to that
um couldn't serve communion all of those
things but I could speak which
as I was growing up even that was a
really big deal which you'll hear more
about later so the way I do this is I
tell stories
tell stories that hopefully you can
relate to hopefully you can take a
lesson from and I figure that's kind of
what Jesus did so um as in all things I
Look to Him and um
he has inspired me to share this story
with you tonight so hope you enjoy it
and learn and and get some peace from it
so I'll set the stage
um
I was in second grade
and it was the
1976-1977 school year and yes I do
realize that makes me very old but there
was a lot going on in the world in our
lives as a family we had just moved to a
new community
we had just moved to a new house and a
new community after being the baby of
the family for eight years I had a
younger brother and my father was
diagnosed with lymphoma which would take
his life about four years later so you
can imagine there's a lot going on
and I was kind of lost
um you know the Perpetual middle child
you know Marsha Marsha Marsha um but I
was lost
um
we got to the end of the school year
though and it was Farm day
and the end of the school year back then
was like the middle of June so it was
summer
and it was Farm day
and what form day was we got to go our
school teacher's name was Miss Rose and
I didn't know until years later that
their Farm was like really big it was a
big deal but um she had a farm she had a
homestead and she would take us all
there to act country I guess we probably
called it a lot worse than that it was
probably hillbilly day or worse you know
it was Tennessee 1970s but we got to go
to her Farm in act country and take our
little lunches on sticks and a little
red bandana and just just go be country
um
and I went for it like I was all in we
got to dress country
um
so this is what I did and some of this
may sound a little familiar to you so I
wore ripped jeans with holes in the
knees and they were rolled up that was a
big deal for girls in in the 1970s and I
had on my father's bricks brother shirt
and yes this is the shirt
um and I was really I mean it was this
big so it was really big I mean it's the
Brooks Brothers shirt it is really big
and uh and I guess it's a lot like
sloppy equaled country and my mom kind
of left me from my own devices because
she was really good that way you know
just like ah whatever you know go for it
so um my hair was wild I am it was just
wild crazy back then I think my sister's
watching um she learned not to mess with
my hair in a very I want to turn around
punched her in the face one night but um
so I just let it fly like I usually wear
it back and sleeked back in a ponytail
or you know two little pigtails but that
day letting it fly so you're getting a
picture right so I went for my little
knee socks my little skirt jeans and
this shirt and wild hair but that wasn't
enough
so I decided for some reason that I need
to put dirt on my face and this is where
maybe Mom should have stepped in or
maybe my older sister like you know
maybe not the dirt on your face but I
was all in and then I remember her my
sister she probably doesn't remember
that she told me on the way to school
that dirt had dog poop in it
um yeah because she was a great big
sister that way so anyway I've Got dirt
on my face I'm I'm I'm there I'm in it
so I go into school I'm so excited and I
look around and all the other girls
looked exactly like they did every other
day
except a couple of them had braids you
know and like one girl had on a gingham
shirt and there I was you know I kind of
look like pigpen at that point hair dirt
shoes
um then we got to the farm you know I'm
still okay because like I'm an all-in
kind of person like I'm still okay
no braids and gingham for me here I am
I'm country so we get to the farm
and we played games and we they don't
took our little bandanas down and ate
our lunches then and it was great
and then as things you know still like
you say back in the day we they
separated us out into boys and girls
because that's how you do it so we're
gonna go learn country living skills all
right
so I Trot over
um little girls and and there's the boys
and they're having so much more fun of
course but I wanted to do it like so
the girls activities that we're gonna
crochet like little pot holders and make
quilt squares and I sat there
I couldn't do it
it was not that I didn't want to do it
it wasn't that I wouldn't do it I wasn't
like I'm such a special little tomboy
pigpen that you know I'm no girl stuff
for me I just couldn't do it my hands
didn't work that way and didn't work
with my eyes the hand-eye coordination
it just wasn't happening I kept looking
over to where the boys were and I
finally just said I can't do this like I
don't belong here can I please like I'm
gonna sit here and make you miserable or
can I just go play with the boys and
they finally Mrs Barnett God bless her
um The Chaperone she was fine yes go so
I did
so um I ran over there in the creek and
I was catching crawdads and those were
crawfish for you Texas people
um crawdads and I had my bamboo pole and
you know fishing
and I just stopped
and in that mind and I just I I'm eight
years old and I stopped and I stood
there in that Creek
and I closed my eyes and I put my face
up to the Sun and I was like
this is who I am
this is who I'm supposed to be and it
was the first time in my life
I had an identity not my mother's
daughter not my father's daughter not my
sister's little sister but me it had
never occurred to me that I was a person
my own identity that wasn't connected to
them or anything else
and you know I wasn't I would love to
say and at the age of eight I declared I
am fearfully and wonderfully made I
didn't say it that way but I felt it
that way and it was like for the rest of
my life this is who I'm gonna be I'm
gonna do exactly what feels right to me
I'm not giving this up and I can you
know the cicadas and the birds are like
this is it this is it it was magic
so then it's time to go home
get back on the bus
all the girls you know I didn't really
didn't bring a crawdad and fish back
with me you know and all the girls I'm
looking and they're like I'm gonna give
my mom this potholder and I'm going to
use this quilt for a Barbie doll blanket
what's wrong with you
isn't you you should have said over
there you should have made that pot
holder
and
I looked got my reflection in the mirror
in the window of the bus and I was like
you're just some frizzy headed dirty kid
there's nothing special about you
and for years after
I felt lost
um I think it didn't fit in anywhere
like in high school my high school
friend groups and even you know my
college sorority and thank God my sister
was president of her College sorority
she kind of paved the way for me she
paved the way for me in almost every
aspect of my life
um
I was there and I was accepted
but I never quite felt part of it was
always on the outside always on the
edges
had a few close friends but even then
you know I just kind of felt like the
odd duck
I got married young had a child young so
I became part of the you know mom's
groups like and I wanted I wanted wanted
to fit in
you know places you know this mom's
group and then I wanted to fit in a
church just so much and like I said I'm
an all-in kind of person so
I read
only Christian magazines I tried to read
only Christian books Christian romances
then you know all of these things
Christian music and I read the Bible
through in a year twice
um but everything that was actually
happening in my life
was in direct opposition to what I was
being told
about a Christian Life
especially a Christian Life for a young
wife and mother
um
was taught
was supposed to be submissive and at
home and under the protection of my
husband and I thought that sounded
wonderful but my reality was I was the
breadwinner I was the faith leader of my
family
I was the one you know dragging the baby
to Sunday school in
and I went to minister for help it was
like what do I do like I'm learning this
I'm hearing this I'm living this what do
I do and he said maybe you could try not
to be so much
or so accomplished now he wasn't a jerk
like this he he's he wasn't a jury this
isn't like the villain in all the bad
movies about bad Christian ministers
like he's he really
his experience for that generation had
taught him you're going to be happier
and your husband's going to be happier
and not so angry if you just do these
things years later he formed a very
Progressive Faith Community in the town
and what invited me and apologized for
that role that he had had in kind of my
spiritual
identity crisis
um
but I started thinking I worry
constantly am I making God unhappy for
questioning this do I still believe this
what does it say about me if I don't
believe these things you know am I even
who am I you know was I even Christian
this isn't unusual and this happens to
people all the time I wasn't unique in
my spiritual crisis
Rebecca drumstra
writes that spiritual identity
disruption is when what you believed or
were taught about faith or spirituality
collides with an opposing lived
experience
which may include abuse trauma and
hypocrisy
this polarization cannot be reconciled
using the existing cat Foundation
causing A disruption of identity in a
crisis of belief so my Foundation were
these books and these magazines and
these songs and all of these things
telling me this I could not use those
tools to heal this Rift I felt inside
so as drumster wrote it's not easy and
it may require professional help and
that was certainly true in my experience
and you know for those of you who are
wondering
absolutely you can have a therapist and
Jesus and I needed both
um
and I still struggle so even after years
of counseling I still thought there was
something wrong with me
um
Not only was I lost at church I was lost
at work even when I was succeeding and I
was successful but I still I felt
anxious and ashamed and at a loss
and why I was longing
um
until one day at work
I was at the convocation service at
small Presbyterian School Maryville
College
and as she opened
the school year by reading from Luke 10
38 to 41 and I'm going to read it to you
and then I'll share her wisdom
as Jesus and his disciples were on their
way he came to a village where a woman
named Martha opened her home to him she
had a sister called Mary who sat at the
Lord's feet listening to what he said
but Martha was distracted by all the
preparations that had to be made and she
came can you imagine going and rebuking
Jesus but she did Lord don't you care
that my sister has left me to do the
work by myself
tell her to help me
and Jesus said Martha Martha you were
worried and upset about many things but
only one thing is needed
Mary has chosen what is better and it
will not be taken from her
so in that moment
telling the story about Martha and Mary
or as we call it in my family Wendy and
Lori
um
it became clear
I didn't have to picture what was going
on in Martha and Mary's house I had
lived it I had seen it in my own life
you know my beloved sister hosting our
entire family her hair pulled back in a
ponytail her face red getting the turkey
out of the oven tasting the sweet
potatoes wondering if the sister
Schubert rolls were burned and everybody
just stay away from me you know and we
counted on her to do that but that
wasn't but that wasn't my part
what felt very natural to her it it
didn't and in all the years I lived in
Tennessee I never hosted Thanksgiving
Christmas Easter you get the picture
so what the Reverend Dr Anne McKee of
Maryville College said that day and what
resonated with me so much she said
Mary did not belong in the kitchen
but she wasn't invited to the party
and then she says she wasn't invited
except by Jesus
Jesus Jesus who said Mary has chosen the
good part and it shall not
be taken away from her
I like to say and ironically fast
forward many years
Dr McKee
became my son-in-law's boss at the
college in her role as a Chaplain and I
told him you know tell her sometime that
she changed my life
um
I always said she gave me permission but
she didn't she she was the message
Jesus gave me the permission from the
moment my soul sprung to life Jesus had
given me permission
to be exactly who I was and I was always
at home with Jesus Jesus never let me
down I was always at home with Jesus but
the Jesus I had read about in the Bible
the Jesus I knew in my heart the Jesus
Who Loved everyone and healed the leper
and revealed himself for the first time
and the second time to women and I was
like I always got Jesus I always got it
was the interpretation of Jesus and the
lens that we were being taught to see
him through where I was uncomfortable
and it took me a long time to understand
Jesus said it shall not be taken away
from her but he didn't say it couldn't
be lost
so we lose it
when we start believing that who we are
and what we are
what we're meant to be is somehow wrong
or not real or selfish
or sinful
it's not wrong to nurture the spark of
life in your soul God put it there Jesus
put it there
spark is sacred and god-given and no one
has the right to extinguish it or tell
you it's too bright
so many days after my farm day
experience and the convocation I
learned got it was introduced to Dr Dave
Randall if you look him up he's like
seven feet tall and always wears pink
not easy to miss and so he has spent his
entire life
helping people not to turn their
strengths their weaknesses into strength
and but he has spent his life teaching
people how to amplify that is what is
different that is what is perceived as
weak to live an abundant life and he
does this because when he was also eight
years old maybe there's something about
second grade when he was eight years old
the school principal told him you are
Beyond Redemption
he's eight years old and he's quick to
say just like I did this guy wasn't a
jerk
he was telling me what he believed to be
true I was beyond Redemption at eight
years old because I talked too much and
I couldn't be still
and all of these things and now he makes
his living talking too much and not
being still because he is one of the
best public speakers I've ever met and
he Paces around the stage the entire
time so think of those messages that we
hear our entire lives that he heard at
eight
um and you know we're we're still
hearing them
um
one of the things that I do you know I
having the career I have I have applied
and interviewed for lots of different
jobs and you have you have all you know
probably done some some kind of things
like this is the you know you're doing
an interview and they're like hey it's
great we love your experience we think
we have a personality assessment
that we'd like you to fill out
um
and one of the most common ones
it's a list
I've never counted probably looks like
150 words on one page
and then and you read the top and it was
like that's so friendly describe the way
you see yourself and the words like
you're I mean everybody's smart enough
to not be like you know unethical oh
yeah that sounds like me or you know
greedy or whatever so they give you some
softball sandwich things like
soft-spoken reserved ambitious is okay
you know so there's all these words okay
this is how I see myself like
I you know and then yes you hit next
and across the top of the page there's
two variations
to other people think about you
or
what traits does it take to do your job
well
so you're not even in the door
with these places and they're already
making you question am I smart
am I likeable am I a good leader you
know what weather I don't what do other
people say about me if they call my
references three verified with phone
numbers and email addresses what are
they gonna say are they going to agree
with my first list are they going to
agree with my second list so we still
here
those messages
we're still hearing them
every single time I have not been
selected for a job because of a
personality assessment it turned out to
be a blessing
because I realized I would have been
fitting myself into places that I
didn't belong
so
just like that sewing Circle wasn't
meant for me
um
these places weren't meant for me and
[Music]
he knew
I have to remember that
Jesus is right there with you in the
wrong place or in the right place he
knows every dream every thought every
desire you have
and I have to remember that just like
working in the kitchen wasn't right for
Mary that day and and usually me and
that the the sewing Circle wasn't right
for me that day
um
it was right
for
it was right for Martha and the sewing
Circle was right I assume for most of
the girls or they just um sat and and
did what they were supposed to say
um
so you have to be careful I mean I'm not
talking about things that are illegal or
immoral or intolerant or abusive or
harmful in some way but someone else's
choices aren't wrong
simply because they're wrong for you
um
my sister is a finance manager for a
department of energy contractor and she
is amazing at her job
she's worked there for 30 years and
rarely takes a day off and she is
amazing and she loves it and it would
have driven me crazy like six months in
but that doesn't make it wrong makes it
wrong for me it's still very much right
for her and I think when we start to
think about our choices as right and
other people's it's wrong it's
it's denying them their own sacredness
and their own special god-given Spark
so I'm going to wrap up now
um by saying I love summer like I really
I really really love summer and at least
a hundred times during the day
I'll Tell Dennis I love summer
and then when I when I look back you
know I think
Jesus was with me that day
when I understood who I was and guess
what else he was with me he was with me
when I was in the workplace becoming
more successful and being able to
support myself because I didn't know but
Jesus knew that the day would come where
I had to leave that marriage
to save myself
to save my children what if I had not
had income what if I had not been
successful what if I had been home and
thought my only option until forever
was that marriage because I somehow
couldn't take care of myself so not only
with Jesus saying it's okay he was
saying this is your plan
so back to why I really love summer I
never I never knew but I love it I love
summer I love it
I work in about two weeks a month I work
in Northern Arkansas and it's the town
that I go work in is beautiful
mountains and streams and the first
national river in the United States the
Buffalo National River and every time I
go I walk there's a trail
starts in a city park and it meanders
[Music]
through some tall Bluffs and there's the
stream and there's a creek and the sun's
just right and the cicadas are chirping
and it hit me
I love summer so much
because that is the first time I knew
who I was
and it I it just hit me I thought I I
had forgotten like I had forgotten that
moment I had forgotten how it felt but I
always knew I just loved summer and I
especially loved having my feet in the
water and hearing those cicadas I just
always loved it and I was like well
everybody loves that it's really nice
but
a couple of weeks ago in Arkansas I
remember this is why I love summer
it's because
I knew who I was For the First Time In
Summer
but this time
I brought her back
that girl
who knew who she was supposed to be who
stood on a summer day and knew what God
had made her and planned for I did not
get on the bus and think you're just a
frizzy headed dirty face kid I thought
you are fearfully and wonderfully made
and you
are going back with me to Texas
so
I've always if I love summer
I've always had
a hard relationship with fall
I've always I've always
I've always felt like fall was for
grieving and my father died in Fall that
probably doesn't help but now I realize
you know really the end of summer is
when I fear most that I'm going to lose
her again
I'm gonna lose that person I need to you
know the mind and the body are they're
remarkable you know they know a lot more
about you than you know about yourself
so I always kind of grieve when I when I
get to the end of summer
but I'm not going to let that happen
this year
and you're not going to let that happen
this year because I'm praying
that the spark in me
is going to join with the spark in you
and the spark in you and you and you and
everybody here and everybody within the
sound of my voice and it's going to make
this light so big and so brilliant
that it will be a beacon
and that we will be surrounded by this
bright bright light
and God's love in a summer that just
never has to end
so in the name of the father
Son and the Holy Spirit I appreciate the
spark that is in you and thank you for
sharing here with me tonight
now let's come to the table
for those of you who are this is your
first time we have open communion as we
should because this is the table not of
the church but of the Lord
it is made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more
so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to follow and you who have
failed come because it is the Lord who
invites you it is his will that those
who want him should meet him here so
come to the table
um
[Music]
foreign
the song we're going to close out with
tonight
um
I heard the writer of this song give a
little story about it and he actually
wrote it for his daughter who he she was
a middle school girl and she was
struggling with her own identity and who
she was
so it parallels really nicely with
Lori's story and earlier this week when
Lori and I spoke we didn't know just how
well this song was going to end up tying
in but I think as you listen to the
lyrics we can all kind of find ourselves
in that same story as we've all you know
probably had moments where we weren't
quite sure who we were and how we fit in
to the grander scheme around us so
um Jesse's gonna lead us in this last
song and you're welcome to just sit back
and reflect on these words reflect on
Lori's message and hopefully find find
some home within yourself
As we sing it
you've got all that emotion that's even
like an ocean and you're drowning in a
deep dark well
I can hear it in your voice that if you
only had a choice you would rather be
anyone else
and I love you just the way that you are
I love the way he made Your Precious
Heart
be kind to yourself
be kind yourself
I know it's hard to hear it when that
anger in your spirit is pointing like an
arrow at your chest
when the voice is in your mind or
anything but kind and you can't believe
your Father Knows Best
I love you just the way that you are
I love the way he's shaping your heart
kind yourself
be kind yourself
[Music]
oh how does it end when the war that
you're in is just you against you
against
[Music]
you can't expect to be perfect it's a
fight you've gotta forfeit you belong to
me whatever you do
so lay down your weapons darling take a
deep breath and believe that I love you
be kind to yourself
be kind yourself
[Music]
you
foreign
[Music]
I think I've sang it once here on stage
and it's hard for me to get through it
without even crying so thanks Jesse
it's an important song Thank You Lori
what a great story
um
thanks for joining us tonight
let's see everybody here if you are new
we'd love to get you know get to know
you better I'm gonna set this down
because I don't like reading
uh we'd love to get you know to know you
better and uh you may see these things
sitting around we're going to make some
more of them
Gary can they fill out the card through
this or is it we still doing paper on
like the new
they can filled out here so it's a QR
code right scan it with your phone click
it go digital
um or if you like old-fashioned paper we
can do that too there's a little box out
in the Fourier it's a tiny table fill it
out we'd love to hear from you answer
any questions you have
um so yeah look for these hanging around
uh one thing we do here at the table is
we are really committed to be an
inclusive christ-centered space and
sometimes that takes some Financial
Commitment if you'd like to join us on
that you can also use the QR code and uh
and give through the website but you can
also put that on the little table in the
four year as well
uh gosh I'm gonna have to go back to
this my brain's leaving me apologies
oh yes this is this is a good one I'm a
people person so if you are in need of
prayer a hug or just general support
and find myself
other people that are leaders here at
the table tonight we'd love to hear your
story and give you the support that you
need
so with that said I'm going to send you
guys out with a blessing if you'd like
to stand
oftentimes people like to open their
palms as we're receiving of this
blessing
foreign
you are a child of God
this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved
you are worthy and you are accepted Just
As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with
be blessed have a good week and we hope
to see you back here next Sunday
good night
[Music]
be kind yourself
too
[Music]
your enemies too
foreign